i do feel an increased sensitivity from
you like there's something in you that's
different than the last time medication
is that what it is that's what it is
yeah it's nice though it's really sweet
he's present right yeah like when i look
into your eyes you always do good eye
contact and i always feel you but i can
really sense like that your
feelings are integrated near the surface
yeah i um
before i don't even remember the last
time i even did yours or
i had to ask them
did they even do ours
is this their first time
and then he had to send me the clip
that's how out of it i was
you're like i don't even know like like
i didn't know that harlan had done it
until he did it you know i mean i so
now that i'm on medication i'm like more
present and i could just
were you worried about getting on it i'm
getting what i want medication
yeah
yeah because there's
for years people have been telling like
i've had psychiatrists tell me for years
even in my early 20s i saw somebody say
i think you need to be on medication i'm
like no because i'm a comic and
it's going to affect the comedy right
right um
even if it did i would still be on it
because it's like i'd rather be happy
and then also um it's made it better
right
yeah it's uh when i'm on stage like
edmonton usually
i would have been
petrified daylight
i all the performers before me were kind
of eating it
people were like eating hot dogs walking
around and i would have been pacing like
what the [ __ ] and you mean how come that
i can't hear the monitor i mean but this
time was just like me back there just
going let's see how this goes
and on stage i was like it's fine
you know what i mean yeah it's nice yep
that's cool i still still i did you
reestablish how small and cute your
tongue is the last time
is that what we thought i think we
talked we talked about it he picks when
i
my top lip oh
top lip but can i say something don't do
that
for the last hour i've been wanting to
say something and i've been mindful
saying don't do this to him dude i've
been doing it
i like when you call me out on it though
but i appreciate your restraint
because you're a perfect creature of god
amen
okay as well as you thank you you mean
you
bridget
kennedy
and your white people
right your beach people and newport yeah
and newport and you guys will can your
lineage will continue
okay
because let me say something right if it
pure baby
you're going to keep it pure and i
respect that okay
unhelpful advice
unhopeful advice you know what do you
remember what this is yeah with chad and
jt all right this one is called uh my
disabled mom is a burden
okay stop that's it no that's not
hey answer that yeah
it's like one of those improv games
my disabled mom is a burden and my
playstation is broken great my disabled
mom is a birded
uh oh
wait i don't you don't know the